- So I'm here with David Coleman
who's the president of the College Board,
and we have a pretty big
announcement/collaboration together.
Tell us more about what
we're doing, David.
- I'm super excited,
'cause today the College
Board is announcing
a broader and renewed commitment
to delivering opportunity.
Which means going beyond
an assessment itself
to make sure kids take advantage of
the opportunities they earned.
But also to dare to take seriously
the corruptions that have
risen around the exam process.
What I mean is the perception
that costly test preparation
has made the ground uneven.
And this exam at its finest
should be about merit,
should be about hard work
that's equally available to all.
And there is no better
statement of world class,
high quality stuff for all,
than partnering with Kahn Academy,
to provide free SAT test
preparation for the world,
which is what we commit to today.
- And I just wanna, you know,
I guess doubly underline
what you just said.
I mean, we all remember
when we took the SAT
there's you know, there are some folks
taking these fairly costly prep courses
based on the idea that it might help them,
and maybe on the margin it did help them.
And what we're saying together is,
that ability to pay for that,
should not be a factor anymore.
- You're exactly right.
And what should be a factor,
is the quality of your practice.
And your command of
mathematics for example.
Which is as you know to
command a few things well.
So as we redesign the exam,
we're allowing kids to really focus
on the math that matters most,
that's the most flexible and widely used.
And the only way to gain
real command of that
is through practice.
- And what I'm really excited about,
you know when we first
started talking about this,
this isn't just you know,
"Hey, Kahn Academy,
"why don't you just try
to see what you can do
"and make some test-prep materials".
it's really about a
very close collaboration
where we work together.
And not just to make a,
"Hey, you know if you
can't afford something,
"here's something nice".
But to make something truly world class
so that we can make something that's
as good or better
than any of the high-cost
courses or materials,
but do it for free.
- That's exactly our shared aspiration.
And we wanna go beyond
narrow test preparation,
to really preparing kids
for an understanding
and skill and fluency
with math and literacy,
that allows them to encounter
a wide range of problems with confidence.
- And I think that's
where we're very aligned.
Because the one thing even when my,
my cousins were,
or even when a lot of my
friends were taking the SAT,
they would take these courses and say,
"Oh, when in doubt guess C,
"and rule this answer out".
- [David] Exactly.
- And I would always tell people no,
if you really understand
the underlying mathematics
or the underlying grammar,
you don't have to play these games.
That the answers will come to you,
and so the way we're going to tackle this
isn't about kind of gaming the system.
It's really about getting
those core fundamental ideas
so not only will you do well
on the SAT and other tests,
you'll actually be prepared for college.
- And the redesigned SAT
makes that clearer than ever.
That's it's no longer about tricks,
guessing is not penalized,
you put your best answer forward.
We're talking about reading with
attention to evidence when you read.
We're talking about a core of math that is
flexible, as you say, for the future.
So it's much less about tricks,
about mysterious things,
than an open exam that
celebrates good work.
And the work you've done
in your high school.
- Well, all of us, the whole
team here at Kahn Academy,
you know we've always been
all about the student,
helping the student kind of
take control of their learning.
And we're honored that you guys would
work with us on this, once again,
very close partnership to make not just a
nice to have tool for students,
but a really interactive, deep experience,
that is as good as,
or frankly I think it's
going to be much better
than anything else out there.
- No, to be clear, this will
be the only place in the world,
and free to the world,
besides on our own website,
that students will be able to encounter
materials for the exam
that are ensurely focused
on the core of the math
and the literacy that matters most.
We will partner with the
Kahn Academy to ensure
the quality and validity of every item,
every practice item,
and make sure that this
work we do together
is of the highest quality.
And there will be no
other such partnerships,
so I think it can be
the very best there is.
- Super exciting.
- Thank you.